David we've seen Paulin have followed
him through his missionary journey
activities in Asia Minor and last
encountered him an emphasis and her
didn't get through some trials and
tribulations there and we heard him give
his final address to the leaders of the
church the elders of Ephesus emphasis of
the place called my latest on the
western coast of Asia Minor and now in
the next couple of chapters we see him
in Jerusalem yeah and there are some
interesting little details here when he
gets to 2 they the Levant it comes to
says areia and he encounters some some
prophets the daughters of Philip the
Evangelist and a guy named Agabus in
chapter 21 9 and 10 what do you make of
this this business of prophecy and acts
well I think it's easy for us to coming
from our church school backgrounds or
categorical backgrounds to think of
prophecy as being an Old Testament
phenomenon where you do thus says the
Lord but it's clear that prophecy was
alive and well a New Testament times and
that there were Christian prophets and
sometimes by the Holy Spirit and some by
by false spirits would call out what
they thought to be truth
some of them descriptive and some of
them predicting what was yet going to
happen and I think this is a place where
we still this still see that ongoing
debate where you test the spirits is a
spirit of God speaking or false prophets
speaking through false spirits and we
have two examples of what looked at them
like complicated prophecy though lagopus
says what turns out to be true in knots
and waves which is we've seen already
with the with the visit about who Paul
and Barnabas were that they were
representing the Most High even though
she said it for the wrong reasons
yeah sometimes these prophets do
prophesy and travel you Chur right
sometimes they just speak their mind
yeah right and and the trick is to
figure out which is which yeah I think
both in action for early Christians
okay so Paul goes to Jerusalem and but
why in Acts does he come to Jerusalem
yeah well it's a little tricky because
here he comes to visit James and one
sense my sense by the time you're
through is that at least in the first
verses of this conversation he and James
kind of go over acts 15 again and talk
about what Gentiles doing
have to do and we've already had that
established what's one of the places
were act seems different to us from the
from the Paul's letters is it's very
clear the in most of his letters that he
intends to go to Jerusalem from the
Gentiles bearing an offering that a very
important part of his sense of who he is
as an apostle to the Gentiles is that he
brings this offering which is to be some
kind of sign of the unity of using
Gentiles in the faith and by strong
suspicion is that what we have here in
this trip to James is a kind of
suppressed memory or suppressed account
of the trip which must have been the
trip bearing this offering that just
simply never mentioned but which really
dominates a great deal of Paul's own
talk about why he's undertaking his
mission altogether we we have those two
chapters of second Karina's dedicated to
it entirely were meant to in Galatians
and at the end of Jerusalem bring the
army offering so what's happened is it's
become unimportant at the end of the
first century is it the case that the
Jews rejected this that James and Peter
or was there James and John rejected the
offering and if that's the case does
that kind of do in Luke's idea of the
Blessed unity of the church we've seen
in chapter 15 so you suppress that and
talk about a visit that doesn't face up
to this awful fact that just at the time
where you're stressing the unity of a
church that includes Jews and Gentiles
the Gentiles send their offering and the
Jews trim it down yeah we don't know how
Paul's visit we have no idea what's that
of the fact that he's got himself in
some sort of trouble exactly
we have no idea right the story that
Luke tells is that Paul visits James in
Jerusalem this is in chapter 21 of Acts
and they have this conversation that you
mentioned that involves discussion of
circumcision and then James suggests
something to Paul that he undertake
about it he suggested that Paul
essentially undertake the vow that these
two better or go to undertake in order
to go into the temple which is a kind of
what we call a kind of Nazarite vow that
they're going to shave their heads and
join in general kind of abstemious
Nisour the days to come and Paul kind of
contrary to the Paul we'd expect from
Galatians says all right I'll take that
on and I'll fulfill the vow I suppose to
show to James that he's still a loyal
Jew even though he is a part of the
Gentiles he has not give up it has not
given up his own Jewish commitments in
order to be an apostle to the Gentiles
which is different than saying Gentiles
have to take on these same commitments
to be part of the church do you think
that's historically accurate or is Luke
being something I puzzle about that what
do you think it sounds Paul's almost too
accommodating here of course he does
tell us and first we need all these a
Jew he does and so I don't think it's
impossible he might have done it's not
impossible
my Paul is so feisty and reformed that
you know having tangled with James and
the people in James yes maybe he was
trying to be a commentary it could well
be that that's easier than right exactly
you say a bit more about James and what
we know of him
well James at James comes up in the in
the in the the non-christian literature
also of the time as being a leader of
the Jerusalem church
he's clearly understood as being Jesus
own brother and in first Corinthians 15
where Paul lists the people to whom the
risen Lord appeared James the brother of
Jesus as one of them if there's any
continuity between what we read in the
Gospels and what we read in first
Corinthians 15 then James it was not
much of a believer during Jesus Galilean
ministry post resurrection becomes not
only a leader but an apostle a very
important figure in the life of the
church I wish we know more about him we
know he was martyred we know he was
martyred I doubt very much that the
Epistle of James was really written by
him though I think it was attributed to
him and he clearly represents a kind of
continuity with a Jewish side of the
Jewish of the Jesus tradition and that
makes sense that the elder brother the
eldest next brother would take over
something of the authority of the
martyred brother so the brothers both
martyred and resurrected in this case in
any case Paul has this meeting with
James and he goes into the temple
despite the fact that he seems
be observing Jewish traditional custom
he said he causes the store secure and
he offers a little defense of himself
here right before they they counsel and
this is one of the important defense
speech we it is it is and part of what
he tries to do once again I think is to
show how here maybe as much as in taking
the bow shows how much he stands within
the Jewish tradition and learned from
Gamaliel who was the the rabbi who
appears elsewhere in this story and then
recounts now Lucas week added now Paul
recounts the story of this Damascus Road
trip the Damascus Road journey and
vision with a little shift there's now
not just the emphasis on the conversion
but as he talked about going to the
temple afterwards as a strong stress on
on his being called to be the apostle to
the Gentiles or to be the missionary to
the Gentiles and in this K in this sense
in some ways acts 22 sounds more like
Paul self-designation in Galatians than
all the stuff about why you persecuting
me that we get in in acts 9 what do we
know about Gamaliel we know that he was
one of the more open-minded
pharisaic rabbis we in calcium and we
encountered him as a sympathetic hearer
of the gospel back in the first three or
four chapters so he's been signaled
already so this is one of those gestures
that Luke makes to say that yeah good
right-minded open the Jewish tradition
recognizes listen we're part we're part
of a long tradition here I'm not just
embedding this exactly I'm I'm adding on
what I received this is not out of left
field or the unforeseen future one
little episode after this speech to the
of defense and his account of his
conversion and all of that is the
encounter with a roman tribune and we
have again the issue of Paul's Roman
citizenship yeah yeah once again I think
the strong stress that because he's
ascending needs to be treated
differently than if you were simply an
interloper
a non-citizen dragged in and that what
we pointed to before briefly of that
kind of interesting contrast where the
tree being actually ends up a little bit
jealous and I I worked very very hard
for about citizenship and has just been
handed to you and that seems unfair but
at that point the the Tribune does what
he's supposed to do and no longer seeks
to punish fall right and this is
important for the developing plot of
Acts too isn't it because it's be called
cause Paul as a Roman citizen they have
to go to ask to go to Rome yeah so this
is sowing the seed is Luke has done so
often the best Luke is terrific at
signaling what he's going to do in two
or three chapters right time after time
after time
Richard Peugeot and look in the
commentary on acts that I read through
to get ready for this and that you
edited says that essentially from from
after chapter 20 on for the my leaders
speech on there's an echo of the passion
story here that you have increasing and
we brought before both Jewish and
Gentile authorities kind of increasing
pressure increasing haste and increasing
danger I think there's some wisdom to
that mmm-hmm
okay we have Paul again defending
himself before the council and making an
interesting little defensive move here
in chapter 23 right when he sees the
council is composed of chooses his team
he says I see that there are while there
are many Democrats and Republicans among
you I myself am and fill in the blanket
and hopes to get 51 votes on his side by
appealing to his party but in fact lots
of evidence both here and in his own
writings that he is a Pharisee and the
and the places where this is important
here are twofold one that Pharisees did
believe in the resurrection of the dead
and so he will claim an axe from time to
time and maybe he entered the epistles
that as one who believes in Jesus
resurrection he's part of a great
continuity that the fact that Jesus is
raised that's news the fact that the
dead will not be raised that's not news
that's the that's the tradition in which
he's lived and also the willingness
beyond the written word of the
Pentateuch to accept the idea that God
gives ongoing visions and
and that explains why he can be obedient
to a vision here and Pharisees there is
we believe that as most of the Sadducees
don't know only was that only what's in
Torah only what's written no new
doctrines no new visions no new dreams
and they in a way Paul puts a bet on
having enough votes from his party to
get out of it and this connects with the
appeal to Gamaliel back there at the
Pharisee so it's very much on booths
mind here to show that continuity and to
show an affinity between the the
Pharisees who at this point we're
becoming the the dominant Alex s is the
rabbi's becoming the dominant dominant
element exactly which it which again
gets back there what we'll look at next
time which is where are the Jews at the
end of this story for Acts okay so we
have those seeds own ambiguities yeah I
think but we also have a plot to kill
Paul we do right in chapter 23 so once
again I mean and maybe it's a little bit
of that there it's not exactly the good
joob bad Jew distinction but there
clearly are rabble rousers within the
Jewish people and there are enemies
within the Jewish leadership and that's
not everybody but it's consistent and
they're out to get him once again and he
needs to be protected
yeah things heat up in these latter
chapters hugely yeah right from that
that episode a little bit ago where Paul
says and then from there on it looks
like that and finally that Paul is
hauled off to the Roman governor of
Helios we know that he had been a
freedmen that he had himself been a
slave he married into the Herodian
family I think so
which may have been true love or a
really smart political move to get
himself some creds in in Palestine but
nonetheless becomes part of the
leadership that that had ties both on
the Gentile and on the Jewish side and I
think had a not very good reputation as
a governor not only for Jews but for
people in general look I don't think
it's on the hit list I think he's not
anybody's a list of most yeah most
amiable another one of those points
where some people try to draw a
correlation between the the narrow
VAX and an external chronology trying to
figure out exactly when Felix and Festus
changed office although that's very
difficult when it comes late 50s or
otherwise would have a better idea and
it's one of those nice places where we
know that that Luke is paying attention
to that history whether he's reflecting
it accurately or not that matters to him
and God and Felix and Festus a part of
the same story not just God Isaiah and
Jeremiah and Joseph and Mary so at this
point Paul has made an apology he's in
Romans hands Roman hands yeah but
there's still more to come he's on his
way